no no hey hey Tony down just a little
bit hey no that doesn't sound like it to
me you know what I mean yeah yeah but I
gotta take something listen carefully oh
oh I used to rage usage and heaters I
miserable smack about you guys yeah
there you go thank you stick close
that's a fart machine kiss that's like
what's his name of the God are dead that
girl vilified anymore I try out for the
shop then I try out for google voice but
I already try it out yes you did the
boys I did it with something no idea
what idea gross the last one yes I saw
let's do it right now oh I got it ready
I'm ready if you sing this song for us
i'll give you five bucks oh my god okay
I'm ready for that okay okay it was left
your child
we're for the man in the night and day
but I never lost one min asleep when I
was worried about the way the things
about a bit goodwill keeps on Shannon
what a prayer it keeps on burnin rollin
rollin rollin rollin rollin on six bucks
there you go to do oh yeah dad I gonna
do get it daddy job dad I thought I
disciplic oh man they beat her up well I
left a good job in the city working for
the man different that a danger I have a
lot one better sleeping I was worried
about the way they might have been big
wave Kazon turnin proud mary keeps on
burnin rollin rollin oh oh no ray ever
and then they go yeah i know the whole
thing yeah yeah here in my hair I don't
yeah Oliver laughter good job in the
city working for the man heaven I a day
but I never last one matter of sleeping
I was worried when we can all my primary
keys on verbal ever hahaha yeah rolling
what up and I Rolex rejoice every Oliver
dance with ya they went ah what are they
were they [ __ ] devotees suck you cheated
shoes why did my pimp song I checked out
our it's Emma p.m. yeah I'm a pimp come
on i'm a pivot along with it
[ __ ] oh I'm appeal I'm a paean
to myself so my [ __ ] as I yo yo can't
my [ __ ] ass [ __ ] you're my little
brother I kept looking ass and I say so
say to my son and then here we go horn
what that's it breathe haha [ __ ]
notorious working was the worst time
ever how's the same been very high five
better I fine one more time one more
time we need a good idea I'm on fire
what's come on thank you whitney i said
on now okay give me a one good we need a
good night oh there we go I loved I love
rap I can't help it to like two naughty
by nature whoo qi